hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2012 chinese action movie called tai chi
zero
it follows the story of an extraordinary
person determined to learn a specialized
kung fu style to save his life despite
the rejections and challenges he faces
the movie begins with a battle between
the qing dynasty army and the divine
truth cult a group of extraordinary
warriors
among them is lu chan dub the freak due
to the small horn protruding from his
temple and his weird attitude
when the cult is surrounded by cavalries
another soldier nan makes luchan go
berserk by hitting his horn
luchan single handily defeats the
cavalry but his energy is badly drained
he falls unconscious after the battle
ends
luchan's strange horn has set him apart
from other people since birth although
he was born into a wealthy family his
father did not take much care of him it
was his mother who cared and attempted
to make a better life for him
one day he watched a group of street
performers while eating when his food
was taken by another kid
failing to reclaim his food and being
knocked out by the kid luchan fell to
the ground he suddenly gained tremendous
strength to fight back and successfully
defeated his bully this was noticed by
the leader of the street performers zhao
khan ping who sensed a great potential
within him
meanwhile luchan's mother was accused of
stealing from her husband although she
did it to provide a better future for
her son
she was beaten up by her husband's men
and left to die outside of the house
however zhao khan ping who had been
following him from behind explained that
lu chan was gifted with mastering kung
fu naturally and that the strange horn
on his forehead is known as the three
blossoms on the crown
in her last breaths luchan's mother
advised her son to be good at only one
thing which is kung fu
after she died lu chan was taken into
jail's care he turned out to be the
leader of the divine truth cult
disguising himself as a street performer
to scout potential talents back to the
present day the exhausted luchan is
brought into the encampment and a medic
dong is tasked to treat him
dong tells him that he will die if he
keeps fighting as his berserk mode
drains his energy instead of making him
stronger if he wants to live he needs to
balance his energy and project it onto a
softer calmer version of kung fu
he advises learning kung fu style from
the village of chen jiagoo
other people at the encampment ridicule
dong's suggestion but luchan seems to
take it seriously later that evening the
encampment is raided by the kingdom's
army luchan survives the raid
remembering dong's last message to go to
chen jiagu and presents himself to
master chen chang singh so he can learn
chen kung fu
after venturing for days he finally
reaches the village but the villagers do
not welcome him warmly he expresses his
intention to learn chen kung fu to which
the villagers always reply that they do
not teach it to outsiders
then lu chan is hit by a steam engine
driven by fang xi jing and his fiancee
yoon yong
yoon yong comes to him and asks if he is
all right she tells him to contact her
if there is anything she can help with
in the evening xi jing and yong hold a
meeting with the townspeople
xi jing a local who received education
in western countries has just been made
the chief of railroad project tasked to
construct a railway that will pass
through the chen village
the trains will transport sugar and
goods from the west in exchange for
local herbal products of the chen
village
he attempts to convince the villagers
that western technologies will make
their future better by installing
electric bulbs around the room
however it short circuits and blows up
disappointing the village elders the
next day luchan meets you nyong and her
apothecary
he asks her to bring him to grandmaster
chan with the intention to learn kung fu
she instructs him to go to mount wu
liang
luchan quickly heads there but he could
not find him
confused he returns to you nyong and
explains that the grandmaster is nowhere
to be found yoon yong replies that the
grand master can be anywhere after all
they are not allowed to teach chen kung
fu to outsiders lu chan gets angry over
the statement and attacks you nyong but
she defeats him easily an old villager
takes luchan and heals him
he deduces that luchan is dying and his
determination to learn chen kung fu is
driven by his desire to recover from his
condition
meanwhile xi jing is desperate as the
chen villagers refuse to give their
lands for the railroad project although
he is a distant cousin of the chen
family and was raised in the village he
was treated as an outsider and not
allowed to learn chen kung fu
even after he got back to chen village
with the intention to help the people
after getting his western education the
people still looked down on him he
compares himself to you nyong the
daughter of grandmaster chen loved by
everyone in the village the next day
luchan challenges yunyong again to a
kung fu battle yoon yong defeats him
again then banishes him from the village
meanwhile z jing negotiates with his
company's shareholders he enlists the
help of claire a representative of the
east india trading company to deal with
the villagers
lu chan still determined to learn chen
kung fu tries many ways to get back
inside the village but the villagers
always defeat him
the old villager who seems the
friendliest to him advises him that he
can learn chen kung fu by imitating the
villagers moves perfectly this makes him
pick more fights with the villagers so
he can observe their movements and
imitate them one day he fights brother
tofu a local tofu vendor he finally
defeats brother tofu with his imitations
of the chen kung fu which fascinates the
villagers
after feeling a great force pushing him
from behind to strike a significant blow
luchan falls unconscious claire and xi
jing arrive back at the village by
riding an enormous steam-powered
railway-laying machine called troy that
can destroy everything in its path to
make way for the railroad yoon yong
begged xi jing to not destroy the
village although he is firm on his
decision
claire realizes that jing's personal
attachment to yong in the village can
cause him to be reluctant to destroy the
village yoo nyong brings the issue to
the village elders council but they
refuse to take any action while
grandmaster chan is still away
lu chan wakes up and his helper tells
him about troy that will destroy the
village
he advises him to break the engine to
save the village and be the village's
hero
that way maybe the villagers are willing
to teach him chen kung fu
meanwhile z jing confesses his love to
claire
unbeknownst to both yoo nyong observes
them from the roof then interrupts them
while secretly taking the troy engine
handbook
she enlists the help of a post officer
to translate the book while lu chan and
the helper deduce plans to secretly
infiltrate troy and destroy it with a
carefully thought plan luchan
infiltrates the engine and defeats
several guards but finds it difficult to
break the engine
fortunately union also infiltrates the
engine with the same intention then they
work together to find the engine's weak
spot a surviving soldier sounds the
emergency alarm causing zjing and claire
to check the engine although xi jing
warns young that they will be enemies if
she destroys the engine union is still
determined to destroy it then it
explodes
claire gets fatally injured and dies in
xi jing's arms making him vow to avenge
her by decimating the chen village
liu chan and yong run back to the
village where he discovers that his
mysterious helper all this time is
actually grandmaster cheng himself the
grand master originally planned to use
an outsider which is lu chan to destroy
the troy engine so that no chen villager
is involved in its destruction
however since yong also played a part in
breaking the engine he is certain that
an army will come to their village so
they shall be prepared
the villagers prepare for the upcoming
battle under grandmaster chen's
directions he advises them to not hurt
the enemies only to drive them away
liu chan also participates to help the
villagers he steps in front of young to
save her from a bullet making it hit him
instead
he demonstrates his imitations of chen
kung fu to defeat the army with
carefully planned tactics the villagers
win and the rest of the army scramble
away the badly injured luchan is taken
to the elders council as they are
debating whether he should be punished
for stealing the chen kung fu
yoong defends him by saying he imitated
chen kung fu openly by fighting with
local villagers and the villagers have
been observing him
however the elders are still firm on
their determination that no outsider
should learn chen kung fu after her
father advises her yoong exclaims that
she can settle the problem by marrying
lu chan making him his husband and
changing his status as no longer an
outsider to the chen village during the
marriage ceremony two mysterious
outsiders are seen entering the village
they refuse to be rerouted and insist on
entering the village despite being
warned by one of the villagers
a battle ensues between them
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching